now tyler o'neill with runners at first
and third ready to work here it is
swinging and a fly ball hit to right
warning track and
caught by braun right in front of the
wall
no further damage
a hit by pitch and a walk ahead of ryan
braun uh-oh
and there's a shot into left field he
hit it well and there's home run number
350
for ryan broad
well he's heating up didn't he
seems like every year about this time he
starts to take over
and did it last night did not play in
game one and his first at bat a three
run
fastball pretty similar location as to
last night this time he pulls it they
don't see much of that vogelbach able to
get
hira over to third base here's jed jerko
two-strike pitch to jerko
and let's hit in the air to left field
tyler o'neil
at the track
and just in front of the wall but plenty
deep enough for hiro so a sac fly for
jerko and a four run first for the
brewers what about that i think the two
uh complete games almost count as double
but those kind of things tough play to
young deep in the whole oh what a play
by paul de young in short
terrific play from the cardinals
shortstop
oh what a play scoring position for
christian yelich the pitch a swing and a
miss on a curveball outside off the
plate yell at strikes out and he was
staring down garcia as oviedo walks
across the line to the third base dugout
you bet
that lineup for the second time two
strike pitch a wave and a miss got him
on the changeup and back-to-back
strikeouts for suiter here in the third
two men out with edmond the runner at
first for brad miller suiter ready
payoff pitch and that's strike three
called that wasn't a strike
[Applause]
good job by brent suter three scoreless
in game two of this doubleheader
and now jerko nearly went out to
straight away left field pitch number 56
by oviedo ground ball left side gloved
by miller out there the turn by tommy
edmond double play boy he needed that
good pitch by oviedo good result and
good defense as well that sends us to
the fourth
[Applause]
oh a diving play here edmond de young
double play no they couldn't get him
diving stopped there by tommy edmund and
what a play that was as they get the
lead runner this is a great play right
here this year the crew two and two
against saint louis
2-2 pitch
check swing he went around and freddie
peralta strikes out the side in the
fifth
two perfect innings from freddie peralta
out of the bullpen
he now has in his career and he just got
hit by a pitch that's third guy that
oviedo has plunked
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah they have warned him you got to be
kidding me that's uh
i mean that's ridiculous
i mean i can't believe i mean the guy's
wild i mean yeah
yeah i don't i don't think that's uh
well whatever
yeah pretty sure he's not out to drill
the guy it's kind of way you know the
you know the season is you know whatever
orders it first and second now with two
away there's jerko the one-two delivery
good slider and he struck him out well
done oviedo good finish for him he
strikes out jerko it's hard to come by
here in game two the brewers with five
hits the cardinals just two
and a change up catches goldschmidt
that's the old equalizer right there
after 99. you dropped the changeup
here's the payoff pitch to miller and a
fastball at 99 and miller swings right
through it away with rc of the runner at
first here's jacob nottingham walls two
strikes to jacob nottingham
and there's a drive left field and
gone for jacob nottingham
not gonna take away another hit
sends one over the wall and left and
it's six-nothing brew crew
finally able to scratch one out
boy he's hit the ball hard all night
good for jake
third homer of the year
and the brewers needed that and
five of the six runs coming via the long
ball
pitching surrendering just two hits in
this game and nothing since the third
inning yep and now 14 straight retired a
ball of strike to justin williams and in
the air to left field
yelich is there and the brewers take
three out of five
from the st louis cardinals they get a
split in the doubleheader keeps him
right in the thick of it it's crowded in
that battle for second